live-broadcast simple and effective tool
conjugate screening and characterization
presented by Chris Langsdorff a staff
scientist for Thermo Fisher Scientific I
am Judy O'Rourke of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific for more information about
our sponsor visit thermo Fisher com
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen will answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming
Chris Langsdorf I will now turn the
presentation over to him
thank you Judy for that kind
introduction and for hosting us today
miss Judy mentioned my name is Chris
Langsdorf and I'm a staff scientist at
Thermo Fisher Scientific in our protein
and cell analysis group today we'll talk
about simple and effective tools for
antibody drug conjugates screening and
characterization now in our group within
Thermo Fisher Scientific we developed
fluorescent reagents all of the probes
and assays we use to characterize our
cells using fluorescence microscopy and
flow cytometry and had a basic level
much of the work we do and much of the
work in in industry and in academia
right now is based on this interaction
of an antibody and a cell and how they
interact in various ways whether that's
by binding or by the antibody after
binding having some modulatory effect on
the cells now an enormous amount of
energy and resources is focused on this
simple interaction today we'll look at
how we can go one step beyond an
antibody binding to a cell and look at
how we can weaponize that antibody to
create an antibody drug conjugate now by
conjugating a toxic drug to an antibody
it gives us the best of both world the
advantages of an antibody being
specificity along half life and the in
vivo biodistribution of an antibody
while at the same time giving us the
potent effects of a toxic drug delivered
specifically to our target cells now for
the for this reason there's intense
interest in developing antibody drug
conjugates to treat a variety of
different conditions now in the process
of developing antibody drug conjugates
one of the critical answers during that
development process is does my antibody
internalize into our target cells
now of course early in development of an
antibody drug conjugate we need to know
our antibody can affect
we bind with high affinity to an antigen
on the surface of the cell but also
critical to success of an antibody drug
conjugate is whether after binding that
antibody can efficiently internalize and
be specifically taken up by the target
cell such that the conjugated toxin
shown here in red can be released and
specifically kill our target cell and so
historically this has been a very
challenging event to measure with
various approaches attempted all with
with their own drawbacks so today we'll
focus on three different methods to
evaluate antibody internalization two
that are covalent attachment one that is
random conjugation and one site-specific
and then a new method that is intended
for fast scalable screening of this
process of antibody internalization so
I'll show you examples of how we apply
each of these technologies to evaluate
the performance of our antibodies and
antibody drug conjugates and so first
let me show you the cell models we use
in our lab to interrogate these these
processes first we have a blood cancer
model with two very well characterized
therapeutic antibody rituximab
and open at uzum ab both of which bind
to the cd20 antigen on the surface of
cells such as these ramos leukemia cells
on our second model which is an adherent
tel model uses trastuzumab or Herceptin
which binds to the her2 receptor as
present over expressed on the surface of
these skb our three breast cancer cells
so both a suspension towel model and an
adherent sell model the suspension sells
we analyze typically using flow
cytometry on our tuned NXT close sight
ometer now this instrument has four
lasers 14 colors and with an auto
sampler we can run 96 different samples
very quickly critical for the screening
aspect of the data we'll show you today
our adherent cell models we analyze
using an imaging system the Evo's FL
auto 2 imaging system qualitative data
for quantitative data from images we use
our 7 type p x7 high content analysis
platform which extracts quantitative
information from the images of ourselves
and so to actually monitor
internalization of our antibodies we
take advantage of a 2 different
fluorescent dyes called frodo dyes both
of which a red and a green both of which
are dark at neutral pH and as they
encounter an acidic environment that
come dramatically brighter as you see in
the figure on the right and so in the
panel on the left when we label an IgG
antibody with either of these dies it
will be non fluorescent outside the cell
only after that antibody binds to
advantage n' and is specifically taken
up through the endosome into the
lysosome where it experiences a pH drop
and becomes very brightly fluorescent
and so we can quantify that to determine
the extent of antibody internalization
now you'll notice the acronyms
IFL proto red and IFL proto green this
is to distinguish newly developed
versions of the frodo dyes which are
optimized for antibody labeling the name
frodo has been around for many years but
the previous version of these dyes was
not ideal for antibody late
link and you can see here as overlaid
the classic versions of gold frodo red
and proto green
we're not useful for monitoring antibody
externalization so the prefer this type
of assay be sure you are using the IFL
proto red or IFL photo green the reason
for this has to do with solubility and
performance of the antibody during the
conjugation process if we look at back
up a step and look at the actual
conjugation of the trastuzumab we used
in this experiment we can look at the
spin filters used to clean up this
conjugate you can see with the classic
Frodo green and Frodo red we have a lot
of color in the top of this side of
exclusion column showing us that all of
our antibody and dye precipitated and
did not flow through the column whereas
both the IFL Frodo green and is all
Frodo red we have our free dye collected
on top of the column and our purified
conjugate flows through and is collected
in the bottom of this column and so
within the new IFL photo red and IFL
Frodo green it's very easy to conjugate
antibodies or any other globular protein
to monitor its internalization so what
we see when we take for example this
Herceptin labeled with I FL proto red
and put it on to breast cancer cells
overnight for 16 hours what we see in a
live cell image is a red signal present
within the lysosome of of every cell
reporting a very robust internalization
of this antibody into the target cell so
a very very clear flora genic indication
that this antibody has been internalized
which we can see qualitatively in this
image
so using closed cytometry we can provide
a quantitative analysis that the
internalization of these antibodies into
our target cells
so on the Left using IFL proto read
conjugates as three different antibodies
Rituxan which is a type 1 IDG we expect
that to internalize very rapidly because
I have a being an IgG 2 internalizes to
a lesser extent while Herceptin which
does not recognize an antigen present on
the cell we see fluorescent signal
similar to the background of unstained
cells and with the photo IFL fertile
green we see similar performance except
you can see that the background is a
little bit higher with the green
so if sensitivity is the most important
aspect of your experiment we recommend
the IFL proto green as being somewhat
brighter well the green is available as
an option if green is an ideal color for
your detection system so in this
experiment we analyzed our cd20 positive
Ramos cells on the attune flow cytometer
we can also drive this sort of
quantitative information from images and
so now we can switch to our cell and
type cx5 a high content analysis system
and look at her to positive and her2
negative breast cancer cells which were
treated with either
IFL photo red Herceptin orgas IVA for 24
hours and what we see as we increase the
dose of our antibodies from left to
right we have a very clear signal
showing specific internalization of the
Herceptin into the her2 positive cells
while our various negative controls give
us the expected lack of fluorescent
signal so this is one way to show
specific internalization with various
controls as extracted from from an image
another way to show specific
city is with a competition a sate and so
in this experiment we pre treated our
cells our sqb our three cells with an
increasing dose of Herceptin as a
pretreatment so as we move from left to
right we increase the the pre treating
dose of unlabeled Herceptin and then we
chase with five nano molar Herceptin
which has been conjugated with IFL frodo
red for 24 hours and so what we're
asking is can we use the unlabeled
antibody to compete off the labeled
Herceptin and block its internalization
and as you see the answer is yes we can
very effectively block the
internalization of this antibody by
saturating the receptor and so valuable
to show that any internalization we see
here is specific to biology and not from
nonspecific endocytosis or other sources
of background we can also look at the
rate of internalization using the same
system so in this case we're again using
Herceptin with our SK br3 her2 positive
cells or another her to negative cell
line and as we'd expect the intensity of
spots in a ring around the nucleus is
quantified by the cell and type cx-5
platform increase over time until we hit
a plateau at around 20 hours which is
consistent across our our other
experiments and shows again the
specificity of the biology we're looking
at and so one other thing to be aware of
is these these antibodies I've shown you
so far have been cleaned up I purified
these antibody conjugates on a
size-exclusion column to remove the free
dye we wondered is it necessary to
remove the free die or if died was
remained in the conjugate what effect
with
laughs and so we treated our ramos
b-cells with increasing doses of
rituximab labels with IFL proto green
and we see the signal increase with as
indicated by the green line as we'd
expect as we increase the concentration
of that antibody we treat these same
cells with the IFL roto green dye alone
we actually don't see a single until
much more free dye is added and so the
conclusion here is that free dye that's
remaining in your antibody conjugate
will not significantly affect the
internalization signal as reported in
your experiment so this this adds some
flexibility or convenience where you may
not need to clean up your conjugate as
rigorously if you're concerned about
compromising yield of your conjugate
okay and so that's a summary of our IFL
Frodo
I mean reactive dyes core antibody
internalization but other conjugation
approaches are possible so I'll show you
two more first I should mention that
antibody drug conjugates are generally
made one of two ways either they're
lysines are labeled via a primary amine
conjugation or disulfide bridges are
reduced to conjugate two files present
and cysteine residues now with lysine
conjugation this is essentially painting
dye or a drug on to an antibody whereas
you see in this graph the number of
drugs per antibody varies widely on a
normal distribution
while assisting conjugation when we
reduce disulfide bonds we're essentially
freeing either 2 4 6 or 8 conjugation
sites and we see the consequent number
of drugs per antibody with all of these
approaches we don't have you know as you
can see we don't have control over the
degree of labeling and also we may be
concerned with lysine conjugation that a
dye or a drug present in the antigen
binding site may affect the affinity of
our antibody while the sistine
conjugation we can expect over reduction
of disulfides to compromise the
integrity of our handsome body in either
case this makes it more difficult to
pursue regulatory approval for one of
these compounds as a therapeutic ideally
we would have a known number of
conjugates for antibody and and in a
known location so we can very tightly
control the conjugation of our antibody
and more easily gain approval for this
therapeutic now various approaches are
used in the field to perform
site-specific conjugation to attach
drugs to known types on antibodies none
of which are especially easy to pick up
and adopt straight away in your own lab
until you've developed our own approach
to site specifically labeled antibodies
this takes advantage of the fact that I
GG antibodies have a conserved structure
and part of this conserved structure is
a MEK oscillation profile shown here in
green on asparagine 297 on both of our i
GG heavy chains
we can use this conserved domain as a
handle to which we attach payloads
whether that is a drug or dye or another
payload of your choice we call this the
site click antibody labeling system if
we look in more detail at this branched
carbohydrate domain on each heavy chain
the site click antibody labeling system
provides one enzyme base especially
engineered beta galactosidase variant
that we've developed to specifically
remove the terminal galactose from this
branched carbohydrate and we proceed
with a second enzyme again especially
engineered beta galactosidase which
replaces our n-acetyl galactose with a
synthetic sugar containing an azide tag
now once this azide tag is incorporated
into our antibody this conjugate is now
stable and can be set aside for later
use and when you're ready to perform the
conjugation you sure Anna Skibo
conjugate with your label of choice on
it as Devo is a strained alkyne copper
list click reagent and so it will
specifically recognize the azide we have
introduced to our antibody and so we now
have a covalent link between our payload
of choice and the heavy chain of our
antibody and so at a high level here's
an overview of this reaction where we
take an IgG antibody raised and
mammalian system so that our
carbohydrates are present proceed
through azide activating it and then use
an STL alkyne to attach them exactly
four payloads per antibody
and so we can show that not only is our
conjugation site far away from the
antigen binding domain of our antibody
which maintains the integrity of our
antibody as well as the affinity for its
target but we have a reproducible and
reliable number of drugs or dyes per
antibody we can quantify this using mass
spectrometry where here we conjugated
monomethyl or statin II a toxin to
trastuzumab
and but the mass spec shows us is that
the primary species in this conjugation
contained four of our drugs a small
subset of our antibodies had only three
but our smaller species are almost not
present and we see this again and again
this is a reproducible conjugation where
in this figure we looked at 28 different
antibodies with varying isotypes varying
specificities and and species and we see
less than 10 percent variation across
all 28 of these unique conjugations so
provides a great deal of reproducibility
in a protocol that was using other
chemistry's is known for its variation
now by binding
specifically to the FC tail of our itg
we can show again with mass spectrometry
that before and after conjugation we
have seen no change to the antigen
binding domains of our antibody so even
though it contains a toxic payload we
have not changed the structure of the
antigen binding domains so cyclic
antibody labeling consists of an
antibody as ito modification kit which
will get you as far as the azide
modified antibody and then at that point
you can choose from a list of different
s dive
Oh conjugates to attach to this antibody
so a few different alexa floors of
course our IFL proto red Estee vivo and
then a toolkit of other compounds so
that you can attach really whatever you
would like to have on your antibody CS
tae-bo biotin making it possible to
attach streptavidin or strip to have an
encoded magnetic beads and the estuvo
amine and a main reactive serving as
linker reagents to conjugate whatever
reactive dye you like to an azide
activated antibody and so a basic level
if we use alex or 48 or alexa core 647
and conjugate those to our model
antibodies that we discussed previously
we can see that he enough for 647 s
taibo conjugate of our gazebo will
specifically recognize the cd20 antigen
on our ramos cells so in a standard cell
binding assay in this case with
suspension cells analyzed with po
cytometry we have a very specific signal
with low background in all of our
controls just to show that this performs
as we'd expect we can see something
similar with imaging in a high content
analysis experiment again a cell binding
assay just asking how well do our
antibiotics recognize the target cell in
this case with Herceptin labeled with
Alexa for 488 s Devo again we see a
clear positive signal showing binding
and recognition of our her two positive
cells
well our negative controls are all
minimal fluorescence as we would expect
now we can go beyond the Alexa floors
and actually combine two things in
conjugation reaction so for this
experiment we used monomethyl or a
statin es5 Oh which happens to have a
conception cleavable linker so that when
this antibody enters a target cell the
toxin will be free and able to be
released and attack the tubulin in the
target cell except for this conjugation
we made a cocktail of our MMA e and our
alexa fluor 647 so the product is a dual
labeled antibody or essentially a
fluorescent antibody drug conjugate so
when we apply this to cells we see in
our her two positive cell line our alexa
fluor 647 gives us a bright signal both
on the surface of the cell where it is
bound to the her2 receptor but we also
see signal throughout the cell where
that antibody has internalized well on
our her two negative cells our signal is
really quite minimal now this with alexa
fluor 647 being always fluorescent we
can see it both outside and inside the
cell if we just want to know whether our
antibody drug conjugate was internalized
we can switch from alexa fluor back to
our i FL frodo die or in this case we're
using the i FL photo red s daibo
compound for site click labeling of
trastuzumab now when we apply this
fourth leg labeled antibody to a
spheroid of skb our three breast cancer
cells after 72 hours we see that the
antibody has penetrated all the way
through this very large spheroid and not
only reports the internalization of the
antibody but we have a second probe here
at caspase sensor we see a couple of
green spots showing us spontaneous death
of a couple of cells in this steroid now
we take the same antibody and instead of
attaching just the IFL photo read as
daibo we now make our dual labelled
conjugate so labeled with both our MMA e
in a clickable version and the IFL for a
red s dye go essentially making an
antibody drug conjugate apply this to
the same spheroid and now what we see is
not only red signal reporting directly
the internalization of our antibody into
our target cells but we also see very
bright green signal from those cells
that have been killed by this attached
toxin that has been cleaved upon entry
into a lysosome so again this is a live
C roid as imaged on cx-5 high content
analysis platform so a very powerful
tool being able to conjugate one or
multiple compounds to an antibody
without affecting the affinity or
performance of that antibody so two
different methods to covalently attached
a payload to an antibody and use that to
report internalization of that antibody
both of these approaches being covalent
require some some amount of cleanup
which is useful for a small number of
antibodies but if we're screening
antibody clones for those that
internalize we need a different approach
and so let me tell you about V non IFLS
row which is designed for fast and
scalable screening of antibodies to
determine which clones internalized now
Zenon IFL Fredo is especially engineered
fab fragment that we have developed and
pre labeled with either our IFL photo
green or I FL tribal red dyes critical
that the IFL proto is used to make these
to maintain
solubility in solution so in an
experimental workflow you'll take the
Zenon
IFL frodo reagent add it directly to
your antibody and incubate for five
minutes or or less and the high affinity
fab which is specific for the FC of your
human or Mouse IgG will very quickly
associate and label your IgG and so now
whether this is one antibody or 96
different antibodies we can add this
labeled antibody to cells in whatever
scale you desire so label your antibody
add cells and incubate for the required
amount of time we saw with Herceptin
that was in the range of 18 to 24 hours
some antibodies are internalized much
faster but then after the required
incubation time take yourselves and with
no washing or cleanup required put your
live cells into either your flow
cytometry system for suspension cell
analysis or into a high content imaging
system to analyze internalization into
adherent cells and so what we see in the
case of suspension cells analyzed with
flow cytometry if we use the Zenon IFL
photo red to label rituximab we only see
this bright positive signal when both
the antibody and the Zenon are present
if we add only the Zenon photo red as
you see in the middle column we have a
minimal signal which makes sense because
we are incubating our cells for 16 hours
with a 50,000 molecular weight structure
that can be non-specifically endocytosis
it's an important control in this
experiment to be sure that it is your
antibody that is delivering the
xenon IFL Frodo compound into yourself
so we have a very clear signal showing
its internalization of this labeled
antibody into ourselves now for
screening in this case we're using a
very well behaved
ie g1 but early in a development
campaign you may not know the ISO type
of your antibody and so we designed this
system to be flexible such that the Leon
prefer to IFL reagent will bind to all
subclasses of IgG in this case we're
showing an Eliza demonstrating binding
at the anti-mouse xenon to four
different ISO types of Mouse IgG for the
human xenon IFL Frodo
we can demonstrate the same result very
high affinity across isotypes so that
whether you know your your ISO type or
not whether you're coming straight out
of a hybridoma or you have a purified
antibody it doesn't matter this performs
across isotypes so this is self free
affinity data let's see how this behaves
actually Intel's
now if we switch instead to a cell-based
assay and now use our xenon IFL photo
green to label rituximab we see a clear
fluorescent signal
significantly brighter than the cells
alone the background or arrow xenon
alone as our control so therapeutic
grade rituximab performs as we'd expect
but what if we subclass switch this
rituximab and recombinant we produce
another version of IgG one but also the
two three and four versions of rituximab
and as we see in all cases we report
very robust internalization except for
the type to which we expect to be less
as we saw in our earlier model with
Godiva but in all cases we robustly
report the internalization of those
antibodies regardless of subclass and so
the models I've shown you so far are
very well characterized and widely
published now with the protec some a
band and Herceptin and so you may wonder
what if I how does my own antibody
perform in this type of assay with this
system and so we we chose an antibody
out of a catalog a standard research
antibody which is actually a mouse anti
human antibody that targets the
transferrin receptor on the surface of
cells and we decided to screen this
antibody using our xenon is elf roto
internalization screen and what we see
is as we increase the dose of our anti
transferrin receptor antibody as applied
to our ramos cells here for only two
hours we found that this this specific
antibody and especially the receptor
it's targeting is very active and so we
get a strong signal in only two hours
with this model but we report a very
bright signal-to-noise where the black
line here is our background of cell
fluorescence alone and as we increase
from left to right the concentration of
our primary antibody they have a very
broad dynamic range of that antibody at
which this assay gives us a clear signal
of internalization now with the xenon
IFL photo reagent it's possible to
increase the amount of that xenon per
well and achieve a brighter signal as we
see with the red line or if economics is
a critical factor you can use less xenon
as we see with the blue line and still
have a clear indication of
internalization of your target antibody
and so today we've looked at three
different methods for antibody
internalization our
IFL frodo red and green reagents are
four amine reactive conjugation and
monitoring of internalization the site
click system is designed for site
specific labeling and covalent
modification of antibodies well then be
non IFL frodo is designed to screen many
many different antibody clones so for
more information about things we've
discussed today i'll direct you to
thermo fisher comm slash ADC discovery
for more information on the protocols
and the way we generated the data in
this presentation thank you very much
for joining us today and we appreciate
your time thank you
thank you Chris for the
of presentation we will now start the
live Q&A portion of the webinar if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click the
send button will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for let's get
started our first question is can the
new IFL frodo dyes be used to label
proteins other than antibodies
yes thank you Judy that's a good
question so yes the new ISL photo dyes
are great for labeling any globular
proteins where the legacy proto red and
green dyes are useful for labeling small
molecules or particles or beads the new
ISL photo dyes are optimized for
labeling protein is especially suited
for large proteins such as antibodies
but not specifically active eyes it
could be something like transferrin or
BSA or other large globular molecules
they very much excel for these larger
proteins well thank you the two enzymes
you mentioned for cyclic conjugation are
used for other research methods can I
use any beta galactosidase for this
reaction
yeah that's true so the beta
galactosidase is used for many protein
chemistry and biological research
methods in this case the the two enzymes
the beta galactosidase and the galactose
the transferase are specifically
engineered for this purpose so not just
any enzyme can can perform this function
we've actually had to do a significant
amount of engineering to create versions
of these enzymes that will perform in
this manner so thank you for the
question well thank you we have time for
one more question
do I need to remove carrier proteins or
stabilizers from my antibody before
conjugation with these techniques
yes so thank you for asking that's
another good question we're with the
Ameen reactives AFL proto red and I FL
Frodo green dies
these will label any protein that's
present in solution and so if you have
BSA or FBS or another carrier protein in
with your antibody kill you'll want to
remove that before doing your
congregation step with sight click
system there's no need to remove BSA or
other carrier proteins there is a buffer
exchange step built in to your antibody
in the correct buffer the correct pH for
labeling but it doesn't matter if you
have a carrier protein such as BSA
present in your your antibody for the
site click reaction to work so it is
very flexible in that regard with the
Zenon labeling it's much thing where you
could have a whole little suite of
things present in your antibody but
because of the high affinity and
specificity of Zenon reagent for the FC
domain of IgG antibodies there's again
no need to clean up those antibodies
either they can be directly labeled in
whatever solution they may be in and
proceed to your cell based experiment
I'm so good question thank you I would
like to once again to thank Chris Lang
store for his presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through May 30th
2018 you will receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that is all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon bye